heart attacks that's the number one
killer like this is the thing that most
people are gonna die from you aren't
Invincible no matter how fit you are for
men and women in the U.S
yeah it's real
my guest today is quite literally lucky
to be alive it's okay just watch this
his name is Timothy O'Donnell and he is
a professional long course triathlete
with over 50 Podium finishes Timothy is
the 2009 itu long distance world
champion O'Donnell from the USA he plays
second at the 2019 IRONMAN World
Championships in Kona I'm so humbled and
honored thank you he is a humble man
he's a gentleman and Jim O'Donnell
second place Timothy's impressive
20-year athletic journey and more
importantly his life nearly came to a
tragic end when in 2021 he suffered a
Widowmaker heart attack in the middle of
a half Ironman race you know I asked
myself am I gonna die two children is
Bill and Finn and Finn was only eight
weeks old at that point so cannot wait
to give Meridian the kids hugs gonna
change my perspective on life that's for
sure somehow Timothy was able to finish
that race placing 11th which is after
absolutely insane life is precious and
it goes by quickly we discuss his heart
attack of course his life and career as
a pro triathlete we discuss his
experience at the Naval Academy and his
tenure as a naval officer advice for
amateur athletes and tons more Timothy's
story is truly inspiring I was honored
and grateful to have him here to share
it with us before we dive in this
episode is brought to you by Roca now I
get asked fairly consistently about the
glasses that you see me wearing on the
show well the answer is Roca all the
frames that Roca makes are high
performance super light amazing Optics
they've got tons of great Styles they
never ever slip off my face and I'll be
sharing a bit more about Roka later so
here it is this is me and Timothy
O'Donnell
[Music]
thank you
speaking of uh Greg Bennett we have him
to thank for getting us together the
great very handsome and successful
accomplished Greg Bennett such a great
guy big yeah definitely a mentor role
for me over the years as well he's been
lucky to have some guys like that around
me it's cool to see him kind of Step
into the podcast thing and and uh and
really kind of embrace it I listened to
the episodes that you guys did together
and um it's cool but he's building there
and it's great and I appreciate him
connecting us
I mean obviously I'm familiar with your
story I've followed your career for for
many many years and uh it's just you
know we were chatting a little bit
before the podcast like what happened to
you isn't that uncommon and yet the
facts of of what kind of transpired are
so extreme that it makes this it makes
for just just insane story so let's just
like out of the gate like
get it out there right like you had a
Widowmaker heart attack in the middle of
a half Ironman right
it's like the most insane thing it yeah
and I do and I finished the race I do
not recommend um
finishing the finishing the race or your
workout if you're having symptoms of a
heart attack that's for sure just for
context uh you're at the you know the
tip of the Spear of elite Iron Man
professional triathlete performance
you've had every iteration between like
second and Ninth I think at at the
IRONMAN World Championships like second
third fifth like I don't know not tenth
not first right I don't know too many
you know you you how many times you've
raced there ten times nine times ten
times yeah ten times
um many times like the fastest American
your best performance in 2019 uh
finishing second second to Young correct
and only American to go under eight
hours yep still the only right only one
so and and being like 39 at the time
right older uh on the older side of
things
um and then the following season you're
in this half Ironman race in Miami which
was like on a on like uh um so the bike
course was on like a NASCAR yeah on the
NASCAR thing it's all and it's streamed
right there's video footage of all of
this in addition to you like having a
vlog about the whole thing which is
unbelievable you're pushing like 300
watts and you start to experience
symptoms so like I wanna like walk me
through this entire thing so uh I'll
just rewind a little bit yeah because
you know
finished 2019 race in my life second
IRONMAN World Championship to Jan
ferdano and I'm excited the goat yep the
goat and um I wouldn't I wouldn't argue
against that one that's he's got a
strong argument
so you know covet hits in kind of 2020
shuts down right and I actually started
getting
symptoms earlier in 2020 uh we got back
from Australia Rudy and I both got
really sick that was the beginning of
February 2020 no one really knew what
covet was yet especially in the U.S over
in Australia was a little more prevalent
just because of its proximity to China
uh
and I started getting like chests
fluttering and all of a sudden it
started to get kind of hard to breathe
when I was swimming
so I'd actually gone
um in 2020 in Ransom tests I'd done a
stress test uh done um echocardiograms
and things like that and the
juxtaposition of what they found versus
how they saw me as a professional
athlete in my fitness level didn't raise
too many alarms but uh
you know I hit the start line and at
challenge Miami in in March of 2021 and
I kind of knew something was off um I
had some trouble breathing and actually
said that Ben Hoffman is good buddy mine
fellow um triathlete
I don't Before the Race I'm like I don't
really feel right
but Jan was there here we are the first
time I get a chance to race him again
and I love racing the best because I get
the best out of myself
so
pin it have a great swim in the front
with a couple guys on the bike
start to get this kind of spreading pain
through my chest and then shooting pain
down my left arm and my uh jaw started
to lock up right all like classic signs
bye I'm looking down like you said I'm
pushing 300 plus Watts there's no way
I'm having a heart attack if this is you
know if I'm still physically able to do
this so I'm backed it off a little bit
and
um just kind of made it through and then
everything just kept getting worse and
worse and worse until I call my primary
care Doc in Boulder and he told him what
was going on I actually called my wife
um Marinda but first of all you finished
the race I finished the race right yep
and you're still what you were 13th or
something like that was just out of the
money
and I was so mad at myself right all
right so you know something's off but
it's not a heart attack like you
wouldn't be able you would have just
collap like we all have this mental
construct of of what that looks like
like suddenly you just you know fall
down to the ground and
I go back to my first Iron Man World
Championship where I dnf'd and I
after that race I told myself you're
never going to dnf another race again
because once you start once you let
yourself do that that weakness like
Creeps in yeah and then all of a sudden
quitting is a lot easier
so I kind of had that mindset like no
like this is just race pain you're gonna
tough it out but as I S as time passed
um after I finished I knew hey this
isn't this isn't right this is I've done
full Ironmans and I started to feel
better quicker than this not worse yeah
and that's when the kind of the red
flags really started to go off so you
call Rennie your wife you're like I
don't feel so good
she says what she says you need to call
Dr Dave right now
um so I called Dave and he's like dude
you need to take some aspirin and get
yourself to the hospital right now
and what's going through your mind when
you hear that uh
I could be
I had a feeling I knew what was going on
and a lot of people like oh just
dehydration and
um but I just I knew it was something
worse and
went to the first hospital which was
down the street and it I mean it took 90
minutes to get an IV and to get looked
at and how it was starting to get a
little nervous
this isn't the place I probably should
be yeah yeah I mean it's a weird thing
there's this juxtaposition between
strengths and weaknesses like your
strength
as an athlete saying I'm not going to DM
DNR I'm gonna push through no matter
what right uh not you know not the best
strategy when you're dealing with what
you were dealing with and the fact that
you're so robust and so strong that you
could literally walk upright into the ER
and say I'm having weird symptoms
they're not going to prioritize looking
at you yeah right yeah definitely I mean
uh especially with everything going on I
mean they had the big
outside the hospital it's like a scene
out of outbreak right so that's right
like that layered on top of the whole
thing and you like to go back to what
you you spoke about a minute ago
um being in Australia having like
fluttering
early code so so basically what you're
saying is you think you had covet early
before people were talking about getting
covet like yeah before there was a test
for it
um and perhaps there's some aspect of
long covid that
that is like an implicating factor in
all of this yeah I mean this is all me
just thinking about it right um
obviously don't have a medical degree no
you're an engineer though yeah you know
well you're a student of your own body
you know yeah and there's two things
there's two things that happens when you
have um I had a soft plaque rupture uh
and um the plaque filled up my LED right
at the top of the led by the the um the
left main
um
artery ventricle yeah but which is not
great but not where you want it yeah
yeah it's a dangerous spot right the
further higher up you go the more you're
shutting off um but there's two things
that happen right there's the actual
there's the plaque buildup which was
happening anyways but then there's the
the inflammation and the uh
the
um in the artery wall That's compromised
right that wall has to fail
so right in my mind I'm wondering is if
inflammation or something related to to
possibly you know earlier
um when I was having all those other
issues may have been part of the build
up to lead for that artery wall failing
right there's the the buildup of the
plaque is one thing that's Decades of
either some combination of genetic
predisposition lifestyle Etc uh but then
there's the rupturing of the plaque and
it's free-flowing like what causes that
rupture and then the rigidity of the
arterial wall right like whether it can
like Bend or Flex as that that like
loose flowing plaque is is cruising
through you know through the lad yeah
and what and and what role did or may
have covid played because of the in the
long term you know inflammation aspect
of that yeah yeah I get it and um one of
the I've worked with the several
cardiologists trying to you know
obviously you want to get the best guys
around you especially if you want to get
back to competitive Triathlon uh and uh
Aaron baggage who I'd worked with that
mass generally since moved on I believe
he's running the um
like sports Cardiology for the ioc move
to Switzerland
but he did say in runners
that plaque buildup in the lad at that
point is
like they haven't linked it but it's
something they see and I didn't I didn't
have plaque built build up anywhere else
and he said the kind of that flow at
that point in the LED is is very high
and and normal for an endurance athlete
meaning uh well yeah it's just it's just
a point where when you're an endurance
athlete and you're pumping so much blood
all the time right that it is a spot
that seems to get compromised is it that
that like gym fix thing you know like
the idea that the the enlarged runner's
heart that uh causes you know the
advanced endurance athlete to have heart
problems later in life at a higher
incidence rate than the normal person
you hear a lot about that right yeah I'd
say it's probably like a little
different because I mean my heart was my
heart size is normal I'm but yeah I mean
in large charts so it's yeah very common
in the sport as well yeah yeah okay so
you're in the ER you're when you're
waiting they're not ushering you in
right
so at some point though they're they're
having a look at you like tell me what
happened
so yeah it kept getting worse uh
actually our videographer that helps us
um like with our YouTube show and things
like that took me to the hospital and I
called it was helmet at the time wasn't
it or uh Kenny Withrow oh okay because
was working with us and still does
um okay cool Thomas got very busy yeah I
know he well he switched over to Lionel
mess in a full-time thing they're doing
awesome great job but you did some stuff
with him early on we did yeah we were he
first started working with us when
Jordan gets into Talbot right I mean
sorry in Lionel and uh I think he he
picked it right that Lionel was the way
to go like he can only focus on one and
he was totally right like that was that
was the gold mine for sure yeah
um but yeah Kenny like he I was in the I
couldn't even walk into the hospital I
was vomiting outside of the hospital and
Kenny had to like pick me up and bring
me into the hospital and uh
it wasn't until they they realized they
did the blood work and my levels were
through the roof for
um you know the enzymes that are showing
signs of the heart
got muscle dying uh right there's an
enzyme that gets released that shows
definitively that you're having a heart
attack yep absolutely which
they also say if you tested like anybody
that finished in Iron Man right
afterwards they would that enzyme level
be through there oh really just from the
effort so there's even a little like
ambiguity there if it really is what's
happening
but they made the decision to bring me
to uh Jackson South hospital and get me
in with the Cardiology team and uh they
brought in the big uh like uh paddles
big paddles and all of a sudden there's
a lot of people around me and that's
when I kind of realized and
in my head that in my you know I asked
myself am I gonna die is this it uh and
that was
that was probably the hardest moment
while I was kind of going through all
this and you know I quickly made the
decision put that thought out of my head
um my son they have two two children
Isabel and Finn and Finn was only eight
weeks old at that one so
definitely wanted to make sure I was
around for for him yeah for both of them
yeah I mean that's a a Flashpoint moment
you know I can't imagine a more kind of
acute Reckoning with your own mortality
and again it's this weird dichotomy
between the the kind of superhuman
Fitness that you have to have to do what
you do which which I suspect gives you a
sense of you know maybe a little kind of
um outsized uh sense of immortality like
oh I can you know I can do all this
stuff like literally you can have a
Widowmaker heart attack and walk around
afterwards like like you know but then
to be an ER and have yeah like it's that
you know but then this is working
against you at the same time right and
then to have like a ton of bricks land
on you and say actually you're human
and perhaps even more frail than you
might have imagined and have that
crystallized into
um you know such a you know an intense
moment with young children
you know at arguably like the peak of
your career coming off a second place at
Kona like it's very uh you know
disassociative uh experience I I imagine
it yeah and it was definitely hard to
get my head around especially in the
moment and
you top all that off with the fact that
this is how you make your living you
know this is how you feed your kids and
not only are you faced with this moment
of
mortality and realizing that you aren't
Invincible no matter how fit you are and
I think that's a big thing for endurance
athletes of all levels we all think
we're Invincible when
fact is whereas you know can be as frail
as anybody else and then on top of that
it's okay
you know not only can I do I know that
death is real right now but I might be
out of a job so it was scary it was a
lot going on yeah
yeah I think there there is you hear
this adage uh you know you can't out
train a bad diet or bad lifestyle habits
or whatever but but I mean you're kind
of like
yeah but I trained 25 hours a week now
like like that might apply to other
people you know like 10 or 15 hours
maybe 25 but like I've been out on my
bike for like six hours like you know at
like normative you know watts of like
you know I don't know for you 300 or
whatever it is you're like I'm gonna eat
like a huge plate of whatever I feel
like yeah you know and I'll be fine
because I'm not like those other people
yeah right it's not going to happen so
you have this yeah and you and so then
you there's Reckoning and you're like oh
actually that's true
and you know not to get into neither of
us are doctors like was this caused by
genetics is this you know all of that
I'm sure you know all of this is
swimming around in your mind but just in
the moment that that confusion of trying
to make sense of this and like how
you're going to move forward and like am
I even gonna survive to the next day
right yeah
so they poke around initially right and
they're like they seem unalarmed until
they're they are alarmed right so they
brought me to other Hospital uh
and they and even the that the
cardiologist comes in the team you know
they're on call so it takes a little
while
and and he the doctor comes in is like
we're just we're gonna go in and look
you know we're gonna
we we don't think we think it's nothing
big but we're gonna go look it'll be
quick and then all of a sudden they're
in there for a while and that's when I
really knew that something was you know
definitely yeah and they finished the
procedure the place that biggest cent
They had you know in there and uh
the doctor and they go do they go
through your groin to do that yeah they
went through my arm your arm just uh
it's preferred you know growing is
pretty common but the recovery is a
little bit harder since you know you
gotta get it to keep weight off of that
area after that procedure you don't want
to rupture anything
um so if they can go through the arm and
it works and that's kind of their
preferred method which is great because
I just I'm left-handed too so they went
through my right arm even better yeah
but yeah they went through they poke
around and um they kind of cleaned the
blockage out and they put the stent in
to reinforce the artery wall uh where it
was compromised and
the first thing the doctor said to me
afterwards and I didn't really know what
was going on
he said well I guess you're gonna have
to find a new career
and uh one of the nurses that the his
head nurse had actually worked at
Boulder Community Hospital
and he also that yeah I know right
because you're in Miami yeah we're in
Miami and he uh he just like let's let's
go on the dock he's like he's like Dad
don't say that he's like no way Tim he's
like you're gonna be fine he's like
I've seen guys like Tim in Boulder all
the time they're up they're riding their
bikes two weeks three weeks don't worry
about it you're gonna be good so uh
there was a little little reassuring
from uh yeah from one of our Bolder
friends yeah yeah wow
um
it's so intense like trying to make
sense of that trying to understand you
know so you're just so out of left field
like you know something you would have
never imagined would have happened to
you at such a young age it's such a high
level of Fitness
um of course in the wake of that you
have this rehabilitative period but at
some point you have to reckon with like
am I going to still be a pro triathlete
like I've had this near-death experience
um I'm interested in in like what you've
taken from that or learned from that
that's informed your life
but often you know people that have
those experiences they have a relatively
short half-life like they're they have a
very acute awareness of their mortality
for a period of time and then it kind of
tails off and you're back to normally
yeah yeah
well uh I think the first thing was
making sure we got all the information
and the second thing was
making sure there was a decision between
myself and rainy yeah
because you know it is more than just me
and
I've had a great career in Triathlon and
I had quickly come to realization that
if I can't do this then that's okay I
don't need to do this it's something I
love to do and I want to do but if it's
going to be detrimental to my health and
my longevity and being around for my
family then it's not something I should
do yeah and that's when we you know
started a really aligned with some of
the right right people the right doctors
and and make sure that we were good to
go
so you get a clean bill of health like
it is safe for you to train
so uh you know and this sense of like
unfinished business like I I was
progressing like I was getting better
maybe I can still you know do this
um so there's the physical aspect of of
the strain that you're going to put on
your body right and I'm interested in
like the stress test that you know they
performed on you because like that would
be you know it's like you don't really
you know like you're not gonna fit into
their Paradigm of like how we measure
these things for the average person in
the wake of a heart attack
um so maybe talk a little bit about that
and then I want to get into like the
mental you know aspect of this because I
you know I have a sense that that has
been a much
um steeper mountain to climb definitely
um yeah the physical side like you said
the the mental side definitely was was
much harder Challenge on the physical
side
uh I actually dodged two bullets
so there's after you get fixed in the
art or the uh the clog is unclogged and
everything's reinforced
the longer you've you have a blockage
the more damage you can actually cause
to the heart muscle so you get scarring
on the heart and that can really affect
the way the heart heart Works
um and how much blood it pumps so
you know I I had my heart attack during
the race and I didn't it was maybe I
don't know four o'clock or so and
it wasn't until maybe 1am the next that
like
the next morning that they they uh fixed
it so there's a lot of time under the
rest there so they're very worried that
there's going to be a lot of damage to
the actual heart muscle but luckily
scarring was minimal and function wasn't
impaired so
Dodge bullet making it through the
actual incident and then I dodged
another bullet with um the long-term
damage that it actually caused to the
heart muscle so I mean I couldn't be any
luckier yeah for considering what
happened to me and I don't think we've
said it but but the the percentage of
the survival rate for a Widowmaker is
like 12 or something like that right
right yeah another friend who's a heart
surgeon uh retired heart surgeon that I
talked to after the fact he's like
they should be peeling you off at the
speedway right now he's like it's like
count your blessings that you're here so
on the road back physically I actually
went to cardiac rehab
and it was it was pretty entertaining
like you said like how do you like
really measure oh we had to bring money
to get Tim on the treadmill
I was probably about 30 years younger
than the average to break all the
records though yeah
so you know most of the we you do it as
a group of like I don't know eight ten
people in at a time and they're all kind
of you know 75 80s yeah and they're all
just churning along at 20 RPMs on
recumbent bikes or walking on treadmills
and I my coach Shirley dibbons came in
with me that first day
and like okay like you can't follow our
protocol it's not going to work you guys
have to ramp it up you gotta get your
heart rate up and we'll monitor I'm
gonna crush this test so we get on the
treadmill and I start bumping the
treadmill up it only goes to like eight
miles an hour so I'm like
this isn't gonna work yeah this isn't
going to work so we ended up having to
bring my trainer in my bike and just
doing doing our own bike sessions in
there it was it actually did give me a
lot of confidence because I did have the
heart rate up and I knew
that they were monitoring everything and
if something went wrong I was at the
hospital right it actually was a big
part of my mental recovery too so it
gave you confidence that you could push
yourself without uh you know any kind of
like real danger physical danger to
yourself
um which is important because that's
what your Sport's all about the analogy
that comes to mind is is like a
professional cyclist who has a bad crash
you know they have to descend you know
just be Fearless you know in these
Alpine descents or whatever if you have
a bad crash like you're gonna hold back
right just get that little bit of
hesitation yeah and and or if you have a
you know suddenly you have a kid and
your whole like kind of world view
shifts it's not just about you
you're gonna you're gonna like that you
know however many percentage points uh
you're gonna be kind of off what you
used to be how does that impact you when
you're when you know at the highest
level of sport it is about those tiniest
of increments yeah uh
that was a huge challenge in uh even
getting on the road to get to that point
was a huge challenge it was I was on
blood thinners
um actually had to be on them for a year
afterwards
so
you know if something happens like on
one of those descents or with the car
while you're out there riding it can get
a lot worse um especially if it's a
brain injury yeah if you if you crash
you're in big trouble okay so I stayed
on the trainer for a while and then I
finally started getting outside and I've
been sort of removed and then you're
outside and these big semi trucks are
passing you on you know Highway 36 in
Boulder and you're like ah you know this
is you realize like wow this is this is
really kind of dangerous out here and
then he normalized to it again you're
like okay I'm comfortable out here and
uh you kind of get back into your
routine a little bit you're also
questioning like
in the further you are from the
information the real information the
harder it is to
um I guess get a hold of it right so
like the doctors the cardiologists
they have they're very verse and
everything and to them it's like no
you're fine you're okay we fixed it
um it's a mechanical issue it's been
fixed you're good to go
but
I don't I don't know that as much as
them this is my first experience being
in there so
there's a lot of questioning in your
mind like okay well is it really fixed
am I really good to go and then you
remove another level like friends and
family who have even less information
than me about it and they are petrified
yeah they're like what are you doing I
feel like you're crazy you know yeah
um and you have a you have a graduate
degree in engineering yeah right there
are other things that you could be doing
right definitely we'll get into that but
um yeah relatives friends Etc but
your wife Rennie who we haven't even
really talked about but she's an
incredible Iron Man she won the World
Championships three times right three
times
like unbelievably accomplished
um Iron Man triathlete yeah she makes me
look like he's like trying to like not
get embarrassed we'll get into what that
marriage looks like uh you know so
you know
where's her head at like in terms of
like being supportive being concerned
cautious
so
they're ready she's an unbelievable
human being and an amazing wife and
it took me a while to really realized
the toll it was taking on her even at
the even at the very beginning when I
was at the hospital we're like okay we
need to keep this quiet I don't know
what this is going to look like
um you know there could be implications
with Partnerships and things like that
so we just need to like figure this out
before we tell people and
but she was at home by herself with two
little kids yeah and like she needs an
outlet and one of her friends was over
and she just started bawling like she
needed to she's like she needed that
outlet and so
you know that was a little bit of an
Awakening like okay yeah like this is a
big impact on rainy but it wasn't until
I don't even two months later where I
was starting to get back to some
training and uh I was gonna do a
treadmill run
and I and she was gonna uh lay down with
our son Finn get him down for a nap and
take a nap with him
and I'm like I'm gonna run an hour well
an hour passes by or whatever I'm I get
sidetracked doing something around the
house I start super late and again on
the treadmill and TV's blasting and
music's blasting I'm running and she
just wakes up from the nap like two
hours later just hearing blasting TV in
her mind she's like
yeah
exactly he's been done running an hour
ago
so I'm running along and door busts open
and Rooney just has this look on her
face you know she didn't know if she's
gonna see me
you know lying on the ground dead right
and uh
she sees me and just goes she's a huge
thigh relief and that's when it really
hit me like oh my God like
this is a massive impact on our any
psychological toll on you yeah she's
going through a lot and she's she's very
stoic I mean
she's a professional athlete she's one
of the best in the world she's she knows
how to handle pain and almost
internalize it
even if it's uh to her detriment
but you know that's that really hit me
hard about what what this has done to
her too yeah so how do you work through
that like how do you come to some kind
of agreement about uh how you're going
to move forward together
uh it's tough because
she know like she was close enough to
know that it was okay but like I said
just a little bit further removed that
it's kind of scary
and
even
I think honestly just having it okay
this is what I'm gonna do for this short
period of time right yeah like letting I
got two more years yeah because I didn't
realize like even at um we both race
Iron Man 70.3 Santa Cruz in September
and she even said out there she was on
the course like
it was until after that race that she
started to let go she's like even in the
race I was worrying worse Tim am I going
to see Tim making sure I was okay but
after that race everything seemed to
kind of normalize uh for her but then in
Kona a month later my mom's texting
rinny like how are you watching this
like I can't watch you know my mom's
petrified that I'm gonna drop dead on
Iron Man live coverage yeah and uh once
again like one step further removed from
yeah from the doctors and the knowledge
that this is okay but yeah and my mom
didn't tell me that uh but she didn't
want to freak me out but yeah and even
if even if like yeah it's that that gap
between like logically understanding
like you're safe the doctors are telling
you you're safe but it's kind of like
when you're on an airplane you're like
you know it's it's a pretty safe way to
travel but you're a lot you think you're
gonna crash at any minute you know like
like that has to like and knowing that
all these people who love you are
concerned about you is a psychic toll
that you're carrying right and
understanding that
it's more than just you with the kids
and all these people that care about you
and impact that this is having on them
like the commitment that you have to
bring to your sport
um while also like managing that is like
an added
like you know kind of mental aspect of
of the training right and it's
you hate to say it's as simple as just
time but there is that component of it
everybody just needs time to yeah to
heal and kind of have their cathartic
moment with all of this
um
[Music]
have there been like do you when you're
so two things first of all like when
you're training do you feel yourself
like holding back or do you like can you
can you match that like max heart rate
or you know those like watt thresholds
or do you kind of like maybe I shouldn't
just you know that I'll hold back that
five percent it honestly I don't feel
like Rich that I got to that point where
I could
really push myself until the Kona build
uh-huh it was it took that long
um
part of there's other factors too
there's I almost had a complete year off
of training and racing so I'm dealing
with a lack of Fitness that I had to
rebuild and at this point I'm now
turning 42 right so there's the age
component as well and no matter how fit
you are as you get older you know your
max heart rate's gonna start to finish
so we're kind of dealing with all of
that but I did I had to do Iron Man Des
Moines in June to qualify and
that was a
that was a really tough mentally I mean
well so after the heart attack how much
time did you take off and then how much
time between the heart attack and Des
Moines because I want to get into that
race yeah so pretty much all of 2021
I I took maybe four to six weeks off
actually with the cardiologist in
Boulder had me on the um treadmill doing
a stress test like the next week he's
like you're good to go
one week yeah I feel confident but you
need to stay aerobic and you need to
manage your training load because you
have to let your heart recover yeah so
training load like hours is minimal
intensity was almost non-existent
for most of that year
and then January
January of 2022 I kind of went back into
that normal training routine so I had a
couple months before
Des Moines to try to get back into Iron
Man Fitness
almost got there didn't quite get there
yeah
we're brought to you today by Roka
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code Rich Roll at roca.com or
you can click the link in the
description below okay back to the show
in Des Moines you're first out of the
water
you ride 412 on the bike right and then
you wrote a 301 Marathon even though you
like blew up in the last 10K yeah the
last probably yes I think it was 19.
shattered like so this is like a crazy
performance I mean for anybody
any pro but to make that like your first
Iron Man after
what you suffered through like is
unbelievable right like that's
pretty amazing
as a I don't know I'm always gonna as a
pro athlete you're always hard on
yourself right yeah you're always you're
never happy with the performance but
yeah I mean as I look back yeah that was
pretty impressive to be able to put that
together but
you know as we talked about the mental
side of it was the hardest part I was in
third I needed all they needed to do is
get third to qualify for Kona which was
my goal for the year to get just to get
back to Kona just to celebrate the sport
and what I did to get back to that point
and I had like a 14-minute lead on
Fourth Place
and I'm walking and I'm I'm like I
should just drop out like these negative
thoughts are coming in my head right I
don't do I even need to do this like I
can I can my family's right over there
we can just go hang out and chill and uh
I actually saw Kenny who was filming
there and I ran by him he's like
everybody's struggling right now Tio
everybody's struggling right now just
keep just hold it together and I just
broke it down to the most basic okay I'm
not going to worry about the guy that's
14 minutes back I'm not going to worry
about qualifying for Kona let's just run
start jogging from a station to aid
station and let's Elise just finish this
race and um if it's my last Iron Man
okay you know but let's let's get to the
Finish Line yeah and at least get an
Iron Man finish under my belt and once I
did that and I started I didn't say I
didn't come back to life but I was able
to hold it together enough to to stand
the podium and get that Kona spot is
that a perspective shift from the
pre-widowmaker Timothy like in the year
prior to the Widowmaker would that have
been your mindset in a race like that if
you were struggling in the last six
miles
uh
you know I don't know
um I I definitely had those moments
before where you gotta you have to
button it up a little bit right but that
that kind of lingering like hey is this
worth it like I could just be with my
kids yeah
yeah
and then maybe that's a product of also
being in the sport for so long right
because it's hard I mean yeah I started
racing Kona in 2011 I hadn't missed a
year right like that that you know you
look at the a lot of the guys you know
have an injury or something that gives
them a break and it's
oh everybody always comes back better
you know they it's like we just need a
little bit more time off so
yeah but I think part of it just time in
the sport and
um it was exacerbated though 100 by the
the heart attack sure because it was it
came in it crept in quicker and it hit
harder
because there was also the doubt like
that this is even something you should
be doing right
but you make your you you get your slot
to go to Kona and and going into that
race uh is you're like having having
gotten second the last time you raced it
the obvious thing would be like well now
I need to go back and win it right but
having had you know the heart attack my
senses and also from kind of like
watching your your Vlog in the wake of
that race was like I just want to be
proud of my race like I want to I'm
proud that I qualified and I get to go
do this
um and have this experience
uh so that feels like a you know kind of
a new approach or sensibility like that
is very much tied to you know the
experience of surviving something
potentially fatal it was and it was
it was hard to understand that even in
leading into the race and it wasn't
until I was out there on the run that I
really had that moment and it was it was
a decision you know I came off the bike
I was still
I think I was fifth or sixth at that
point running down and leaky I was very
much in that race yeah and uh
but I kind of got out mile eight or nine
and I was on the uh Queen k
and
I was at that point where I didn't feel
great I wasn't as fit as I probably
needed to be to
run well off of the ride I just put
together
and I and I know I've been there before
right that you can things can go really
wrong out here so I I was definitely
holding back there because I wanted I
made the decision that this is
this isn't about trying to go for a top
ten I've been you know I wasn't going to
run onto the podium at that point you
know I've been in the top 10 plenty of
times this was about
me coming back and the support of
everybody around me to get me to this
point not only my family coaches
teammates but the whole Triathlon
Community I mean the support I've had
was unbelievable so I really wanted that
moment to be something that I enjoyed
and that we could all enjoy together and
it made it made running down that Finish
Line even though it wasn't you know my
best finish
probably
my best moment in Triathlon but you had
a great race you performed quite well
and you were your 13th I think 13th yeah
but on another year you would have been
like I don't know fifth or fourth or
something like that I mean it was just
an unbelievable year I mean yeah 802 on
any other year would be
yeah yeah it was right there yeah you
know weird
about this year like like uh there were
so many uh you know veteran Pros who
were actually having really good races
who were just non-factors and I watched
the whole like live stream and they were
like you know like Lionel and you know
like barely mentioned because they were
so far you know behind the the tip of
the spear
um even like you know cam worth who's
coming in here in a couple days I can't
wait to talk to him as well yeah bite
course record holder who you would think
if you're watching the lot following the
race like oh he's way off his game he's
like not even anywhere near the front he
still breaks the bike course record
doing great but there were just all
these guys yesterday now like it was a
real nice guys very like definitive like
seismic shift like here's a new
generation of people this sport is
changing it's changing really quickly
and this is the the the new crop like a
Changing of the Guard Conan made that so
evident yeah I mean it and I think
there's a couple factors you know we had
a big break right you know right in 19
versus code of 2022
but because we missed those races in
between you normally get like one or two
rookies
that come into a race you have high
hopes for every year but because they
they don't have the numbers they almost
just
kind of fall into line with how the race
is playing out but here we had this
critical mass of young guys new to Kona
yeah and they didn't care and they
didn't get stuck into the group think of
how the old guys do it they're like no
like let's go boys and I think that
Dynamic of having all those new guys
there at the same time really led to
that and and kind of casual about the
whole thing you know like oh yeah I
wrote this right yeah like like it was
no big deal like not like you know like
the older guys going holy like
they're so much better they're so much
faster you know I you know you had the
Norwegian fellas here yeah a couple
months ago and and and all off their
coach and they were very matter of fact
of like this is what we're gonna do and
they did it and they executed they
executed perfectly and and and none of
this like I know you you've worked with
Mark Allen right so you're steeped in
the mysticism of the island and the the
kind of vicissitudes of Madame pele's
you know uh you know decision to support
or not support yeah and and you know
kind of being in sync with that you know
vibration being an important aspect of
how you approach that race and and and
and race that race and I asked uh I
asked Gustav I was like yeah what do you
think about like he's like yeah it
doesn't get here he's not gonna be
rolling his eyes
I put no Credence in that whatsoever and
like he's Young and the first time he
did it he won so it's like it's
understandable that he's like I don't
understand why everyone gets caught up
about that
I think there's two things there I do
think
the shift in weather it's it's not the
same race
in terms of conditions I think they used
to be well the conditions were
unbelievable this year but they've been
you know the race got shifted a little
bit earlier in the morning which helps
um
and then yeah I mean 18 the conditions
in 18 were amazing too I mean Daniella's
race that was kind of the equivalent of
what you know the Norwegians and Sam
later did this year
um but yeah that attitude they have and
I'm a little bit envious actually rich
yeah I feel
like I love to see it but I feel like my
generation we didn't like after Chloe
between Crowe and now like we didn't
step up like we could have you didn't
you didn't uh like feel like sort of
iterate yeah on what they established
you know we I think we all kind of fell
in line with that thought of like this
is how it has to be and you have to be
patient and all that
we didn't have anybody that really um
questioned that yeah yeah interesting so
when you look at at like the Norwegian
methods and what Olaf is doing and all
of that like what do you take away from
that like what do you what what what do
you like you look at that and say oh
actually
I should use some of this and this and
this or maybe not that
yeah I think uh
you know they're using a lot of stuff
that's been around but they're using it
in different ways like lactate testing
like I've been in the lab many times
done at one-offs but the way they're
incorporating into the training I think
is taking it to the next level I mean
there are some factors like shoes and
aerodynamics on the bike that are just
making everybody faster and particularly
on the bike when your efficiency gets so
much better uh you know you're not
spending as much energy on the break and
you can you can run better
um I do
I I get nervous about like the
sugar
glycogen spikes that and that kind of
like really like racing at that High
um
high level
how that'll play out in the long run
meaning like you're so you're wearing a
CGM right now I can see it on your arm
super sapiens yeah
um so you're able to monitor your
glucose levels in real time all the time
this is a big thing that the Norwegians
are are really looking at and studying
so when you say when you say like
um
the spiking like what are you talking
about specifically well yeah I think
right now it's I mean glycogen you need
the glycogen to
it's it's a numbers game right yeah be
able to perform for that long with those
numbers you got to be burning a lot of
fuel
um
I just don't know how when you're
operating at that high level of um like
blood glucose levels
how that will play with inflammation and
right and
the long-term implications on that yeah
long-term metabolic health and and
insulin resistance over time right
yeah and some of the advice I've gotten
going back to the heart is don't like
every time you spike your blood sugar
you're triggering inflammation that is
the worst thing for your heart
yeah and you're 43 now 42. uh yeah I'll
be 43 43. yeah
um yeah when you're when you're like
Christian Gustav is like whatever you
know like you're in that Superman
infallible like Immortal stage of your
life three Red Bull three Red Bulls and
two shots of espresso at 4 30 in the
morning like let's go
um before the podcast I was sharing with
you uh I've got a galley of this new
book called outlive by Dr Peter attia
it's coming out this spring he's coming
in here next week and it's the thesis of
this book it's it's really it's a very
grounded kind of uh look at
um extending not just lifespan but
Health span through the you know
prevention or delay of the biggest
causes of mortality which are heart
disease right or heart attacks diabetes
uh obesity
metabolic and it's all about like
um all of these things are rooted in
metabolic dysregulation so he's a big
proponent of using cgms and trying to be
ahead of the curve in terms of like how
our body is metabolizing the food that
we eat and the stress that we incur and
all these sorts of things and it's super
interesting and of course yes it relates
to inflammation and all of these things
are interrelated in a way that we don't
uh appreciate adequately like we treat
them separately well type 2 diabetes and
heart diseases are two separate things
well actually you know like
you know there's a lot yeah like the
Venn diagram overlaps quite a bit on all
of this sort of stuff and so for you
being at your age who's still an elite
professional athlete who has you know
suffered this heart attack and I'm sure
has learned a lot about heart health
like
what are the things that you've taken
away in terms of a like your own
um
your own habits around lifestyle
nutrition diet Etc and and kind of the
advocacy piece of of like what you want
you know the normal person out there to
understand about what you know how we
should
be uh you know thinking about our heart
health and testing Etc
yeah I mean I think
first and foremost
everybody should learn their family
history and know the warning signs
and
those are things that I neglected and
fortunately
the silver lining for everything that's
happening is happening to me is that I
do have a platform now that I can talk
about this and bring awareness and I've
had so many emails and people coming up
to me at races saying thank you you
brought this education to me or a family
member and you you've helped us step in
and prevent you know worse things
happening from existing heart issues so
that's been huge you know
uh so so okay so in your case uh family
history is what on my father's side we
had well my my mother said we had a
heart attack but I believe most of the
genetic stuff is from your from the uh
from your father's side and we we had
coronary artery disease quite a few of
his ancestors and he actually had this
whole like I don't know if it was 23 me
or one of those things yeah and I'm
flipping through this and like oh my
gosh like they had people going way back
family members like everybody's like
coronary artery disease and not just
like a heart issue
you know an artery issue which is you
know what I had except one guy who I
think fell on a train track and was you
know hit by a train I'm like okay that
one's not heart related but at what age
like he might have had a heart attack
yeah yeah yeah yeah but I was going way
back that was right around the early
1900s or something yeah so robust
history there yep
um you know myself also like my
grandfather was a he was captain of the
swim team at University of Michigan in
the 1920s and
stayed fit his whole life and died of a
heart attack at 54.
so when I turned 54 like and he and I'm
named after him like it's you know you
think about your you know it definitely
was living like a present you know
awareness you
um in my like kind of daily
Consciousness that you know I didn't
have before that so
um it just makes you aware you know of
your mortality yeah you know in a way
but anyway so so uh warning signs then
like you mentioned you know obviously
chest pain chest pain uh shortness of
breath huge huge warning sign if it
feels like someone's sitting on your
chest
uh that's that's a good you know
indication that there's an issue
obviously you know the the left arm that
the jaw also signs
just the jaw happen on both sides or
just on the left side uh usually left
side I believe yeah
and that's because the LED left
um ascending
what does it stand for
um interior interior descending right
okay
um that's because that affects that side
of the body I believe yeah yeah
um or um
Rich if you're if you're just noticing
performance drops if you're an athlete
and you like all of a sudden like things
seem a little bit harder there might be
a a slowing of your blood flow from
right maybe calcified plaque and you're
not agree and then there's a series of
tests that you can do I mean you can do
a calcium scan there there's been some
advances in the types of scans though
right
um and that actually was a big part of
me coming after Des Moines of really
getting confidence back so I had done a
calcium uh scan even before the heart
attack it showed calcified plaque in the
LED not a ton but where there's
calcified plaque there's soft black so
that's that's can really give you the
issues give you the trouble rupturing
and you end up where I ended up
but after Des Moines I started actually
having some palpitations and fluttering
I got super nervous
um
turns out I did have a little bit of a
abnormal rhythm but that was just from
hey you're really dehydrated you did a
hot humid Iron Man he shocked your body
your uh electrolytes are out of balance
so it's an electrical issue
no no problem but I'm obviously wanted
to monitor that I put a halter monitor
on for a couple days and we monitored
everything
not a big deal but I also then went and
did a it's called a clearly scan and
that can actually uh it's a non-invasive
way the only non-invasive way to show
Soft plaque and I did that paid out of
pocket for it I don't care it's peace of
mind I need it and it did it really gave
me a lot of confidence we saw everything
everything looked good every you know
everything was this Stenton was working
all that stuff
so how does that work that test
um it's it's almost I think it's somehow
done off of like a CT scan and it shows
so the difference with that is it shows
soft plaque versus like versus just
calcified deposits right
interesting and so you're all good on
that yeah I was yeah and that's when I
like all right let's go let's let the
raises right but that wasn't until like
July or August so I had a pretty short
Runway going into the world Champs
uh-huh so so in terms of like the
average person maybe the semi-fit person
whatever like whoever's listening to
this like what is the you know I I guess
like the ideal time to get tested is is
like today right like doesn't matter how
old you are or whatever how fit you are
or how overweight or or not overweight
you are I mean you're like the Pinnacle
of Fitness so we think of people who are
having heart attacks as being sedentary
overweight people who smoke and have
terrible diets Etc and so it's shocking
you know to hear like somebody like you
just wouldn't thank somebody like
yourself that this would happen
yeah and I think
especially if you know you have a family
history definitely get looked at
um my my siblings I'm the youngest of
four and they were all like yeah this
happened uh you know they all go get in
touch yeah they all think they're like
man we're screwed up this side he's the
best yeah
and how did those I mean are they okay
yeah everybody's good yeah yeah good
good
um and then in terms of of of
any kind of Lifestyle habits that you've
changed as a result
this is the part I actually struggle a
little bit with Rich because
my bandwidth with everything it's been a
lot yeah to manage and I noticed that in
Kona I just didn't have that fight like
it was such a mental emotional toll to
get back to that point that
it you know that's when I realized how
much this had all really taken out of me
um and I get mixed things from from
different Specialists right um I
expected everybody to tell me to go
vegan and
you know
I need to talk to like I know John
Joseph as a cardiologist that he wants
me to talk to um so okay I'll probably
talk to him when I retire but
um the really only feedback I got was
hey
um
don't like avoid red meat basically like
if it swims or flies it's going to be
better for you in terms of inflammation
yeah and and I would imagine keeping an
eye on like LDL APO B and like some of
these blood markers and it's huge and
you have to go beyond uh your total
cholesterol and your LDL HDL
um you know uh I work with inside
tracker and now they have APO B which is
a big indicator of hey okay right that's
that's like everyone's sort of I think
everyone was pushing inside tracker for
a while to have that together because
that has become like the you know most
important marker yeah but you can go
even further than that the size of your
LDL particles is huge and that's another
issue I have I have small LDL particles
that makes it easier to right kind of
get through a compromised artery and
collect
um and just different Transportation
methods which is the lipoproteins and
how they bond to things and
um I do know I need more to get more
fiber in and that's another thing that
I've kind of cut out gluten I had a lot
of stomach issues with the first Kona
and
um linky gut and all that stuff
now that I've learned more I've kind of
realized hey maybe it's more of avoiding
process stuff versus you know good clean
weed or yeah you know a sourdough or
just looking at things that are that are
producing inflammation in your body also
right yeah and that's a good thing with
blood testing too is is yeah monitoring
inflammation and then those particular
um markers right right I did genetic
testing as well and sure enough there's
like four markers that were red flags
yeah
cardiovascular disease like so how are
you like moving forward now like you're
you're you're you're coming off of you
know a Kona that you're proud of
um like what is the you know the short
and long-term future look like for you
as an athlete father or you know
Advocate Etc it was definitely a hard
um this discussion with with Rennie and
like what's this year going to look like
I wanted to race I actually woke up the
next morning and code and I'm like okay
I've closed that chapter
like I came back I closed but what about
performance I think I can still perform
so then I'm like
like that wasn't about performance that
was that was more shocking that that
occurred to you but uh unfortunately
Kona is
only going to be a women's race this
year with the new format The Men's World
Championship will be in nice so I've
decided I'm not going to do that right
now I'm just going to do a couple races
that I I want to do for the love of
racing and and to try to get back and
and win a race and uh hopefully do maybe
one more Iron Man in this in the fall
but right
um I mean we talk about inflammation and
markers like
it takes a toll yeah training that much
you can I can see that my blood work
um so it's not a recipe for longevity it
isn't no yeah and that's what I'm the
cardiologists I'm working with and you
know we had before
um we started recording mentioned
statins a little bit and I'm not
currently on a Statin so you were
previously after the first year I was
and so what was the decision to stop it
really was about training
um it impeded your your ability yeah it
causes a lot of muscle soreness and a
lot of issues with with trying to train
and you know my doctor friends
have inside jokes they'll be on a ride
and all of a sudden someone's not riding
that well anymore he's like oh he just
got on a Statin
right but uh you know we just talked
about it it's not a short term
um it's a short-term thing it's not a
long-term thing and that's how we've
approached it
the best argument I've gotten for being
on a Statin is that it can actually
calcify soft plaque so it can take some
of that dangerous soft black and
stabilize it
um
which is the consideration I have to
definitely look more into but yeah they
said that's a long-term thing you know
you get through racing this year year
and a half and and
that's a plan that will develop when you
get done right
so another year
yeah maybe I think so we'll see
I'm not gonna put I don't want to push
it I don't want to push my luck I don't
want to push my luck and how does uh I
mean obviously you know these are family
decisions your partner you know knows
the landscape better than anybody like
how how is that like being married to
you know an extraordinary athlete who
does the same thing that you do I I
imagine there's there's benefits but it
also maybe makes it challenging
yeah there's definitely um it's there's
you know you gotta there's the good and
bad things I mean Timothy she's more
successful than you she's way more
why am I on here she should be sitting
here I'd love to talk to her
um it was actually it was hard because
when we started dating she was I was
almost like a newcomer right I've been
doing short course I was on the national
team I was Olympics was on my mind and
she was getting ready we started dating
in kind of 09 and she was getting ready
for that first world championship
um
so was that the one where she just
exploded onto the scene it was yeah she
ended up second she ran like 256 in the
zoo shoes back in the day yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so she's not in the Super
Shoes she's not in a rocket X or you
know whatever making her go fast by any
means so
um yeah it was for me it was a little
difficult to find myself I guess because
you're
you're here with the world's the world's
best and there is obviously stuff to
learn but
everybody does it a different way at the
same time so it almost took me a couple
years to start to realize hey this is my
path this is my journey this is the way
I need to do it and it probably wasn't
until 2015 where I had that first podium
in Kona where
I
was comfortable or confident enough in
myself to say okay
I always have all the love and the
respect in the world for my wife
she's done it this way and it's worked
it's worked three times
but I'm me and this is my journey and
this is the way I need to do it you have
different training philosophies and
methods and different coaches and stuff
uh we uh we do well she started working
with Julie dibbons I've been working
with Julie for a couple years since
2018. uh she really seriously was her
right kind of that coach yeah yeah they
had a little break and then she got back
into it and Siri
really I'm like you said I'm an engineer
like I like to dig into stuff really is
so simple
she's like let's do the work uh-huh I'm
gonna nail it this is my goal this is
where I'm going this is what I'm going
to do and I'm just going to make it
happen and Siri was perfect for her and
that series not a
uh she doesn't you know a super
technical coach she'd be like 40 50s you
know we're gonna they're gonna be Bing
bam boom you know they're they're gonna
be fast okay I don't know what that
means but like let's just work hard and
that was perfect for rainy and for you
for me I needed um
probably needed more help less Talent so
I need to learn how to get more
aerodynamic on the bike Eileen I needed
to learn how to run a little bit more
efficiently because those were
weaknesses of mine sure but those are
engineering problems they are yeah right
sometimes they take time time to solve
yeah it's it's
you know all right try this and okay it
didn't work evaluate it go back
you know see what happens and then just
keep tweaking and tinkering yeah and how
is it being part of the Boulder
Community like where everyone is I mean
there's there's a camaraderie right like
there's a sort of a spree decor like so
many people are into multi-sport and
everybody's super fit and out getting
after it
um but a lot of Pros live there and you
know it's got to be does that is there
like a fatigue with that also like where
you're going out and like kind of
everybody's got the same goal and I
would imagine that you know you know
there's challenges with that there was a
fact
you don't you only put yours you only
surround yourself with the people you
want to be around right so I mean there
are so many people in Boulder actually
you know Aaron Royal was here um you
know Australian Professor yeah he was in
Boulder for a little while last year I
didn't even know so well everyone's in
their basements yeah training right now
you're all in Boulder for like we
haven't even had any sunshine it's very
weird very weird I feel like I'm back on
the East Coast
um but yeah you can I mean you surround
yourself with the people you want to and
right I mean I I have great training
partners
um but they're all younger and they they
throttle it so I have to be um right I
have to be a little careful about what
yeah you know what I get into and
training and I don't let my ego get get
the best of me right right right yeah
when you go out with other people you're
either going too hard or too easy right
but you're rarely doing what you're
supposed to be doing yeah you know what
I've actually found is the hardest is
when um
like uh age group athlete or something
wants to come and ride with you and uh
they get that's their moment well they
can yeah or they get nervous they don't
want to like hold you back and then you
just end up getting they ended up giving
it to you you're like you know like this
is trying to settle down you know
um
I want to talk a little bit about uh
your background uh I think there's some
interesting stuff here so you uh your
first sport was swimming yeah and then
you went to the Naval Academy right so
did you grow where did you go you grew
up in
California Pennsylvania you went to like
a seminary school right I do my high
school Wyoming Seminary not it wasn't a
it wasn't like a proper Seminary it was
a private day slash boarding got it but
we grew up my dad was in the corporate
Automotive world and we grew up
everywhere we got into swimming we lived
in Northern California outside of
Sacramento and Roseville
um actually the Summer Sanders her
original sometime as well she was a
little bit before me but yeah uh the
sugar bears nice that's where we all
started and then we started moving
around but I was the worst swimmer in my
family hmm I mean my family still
scratches their head that I've made a
career out of being a professional
athlete I mean I was hopeless when I was
a kid
so but you did it throughout high school
and ended up like what you wanted to be
you wanted to be in the Navy like what
was the impetus to go to the Naval
Academy no I didn't I had no originally
had no desire my older brother Thomas uh
who's a couple years older than me
he always wanted to go to Annapolis
always did and uh he went there and I
seemed to kind of follow Thomas
uh I guess I emulated him he he was a
great student I'm like I'll be a great
student he's a distant swimmer okay I'm
gonna be a distant swimmer and uh then
he goes to Naval Academy I'm like okay
I'll go check it out so I went and
visited him and
I I just I fell in love with
um
just the sense of Duty and the sense of
there being something more than just a
college experience I really felt like
there's a purpose for being there and an
honorable purpose yeah especially so
that that kind of Drew Me In uh-huh and
did you did you swim competitively at
the Naval Academy I did I swam uh I swam
my first two years there
[Music]
my swimming career was really based off
of
training harder than everybody else yeah
you and me both yeah I mean I didn't
have I didn't have the goods but I I
prided myself on knowing that I could
work harder than everybody else right I
mean my coach it'll take you pretty far
it's just not going to take you all the
way yeah and it was a now I look back
like especially ahead when I had to
start working on my running like man I
wish I had taken the time to become a
more efficient summer work on my stroke
because I could have I could have been
better than I was yeah
um it's a beautiful pool there though
I'm from Maryland like I so I swam lots
of meats at the Naval Academy poll over
the years yeah I remember when uh
when I was there I came into practice
one day and there was an age group meet
and uh our coach was like yeah this kid
just crushed the uh I know yeah the pool
record and the 200 free record just
destroyed it we're like well what's his
name uh Michael Phelps right he's 12 or
something yeah right
um and then uh and so so talk to me
about like your kind of career in the
Navy like you so you study like Naval
engineering right like you're going to
be a shipbuilder or something and then
you go to graduate school Berkeley but
do you are you do you become a naval
officer or what is your relationship
with the Navy because I know also like a
big thing with you like you've got the
red white and blue kit and like there's
a you know there's a certain you know
kind of relationship that you've
maintained
um to you know that experience so I just
I'm curious to learn more about that
yeah so when I went to the Naval Academy
um there's a five-year commitment
everybody uh graduates and everybody
that graduates is commissioned as an
officer in the United States Navy and uh
I you know so go to the academy had no
never done a triathlon didn't even know
what Triathlon was at that point I knew
I'd seen the Timex watches let's say
Iron Man right that's all I know I
didn't know what it meant
and uh
I uh my brother Thomas was an ocean
engineer and it was time to go pick a
category like you know uh majors and I
went like well I don't want to do
everything Thomas does but I'll do naval
architecture which is like a subset of
ocean engineering so you know I picked
that and I had the most interesting Navy
career I think of of anybody
um you have a five-year commitment uh a
qualify for a program called the media
graduate education program which allowed
you to go to a grad school if you were
accepted you had to be in the top like I
don't know five percent of the class and
you had to get a scholarship from that
school where there's only two schools
that have ocean engineering programs in
the country and it was Michigan or Cal
Berkeley I'm like whoo I'm in Triathlon
at this point I am yeah I quit swimming
I was full on Triathlon and then and the
academy had a triathlon team we had a
club team so it wasn't a Varsity Sport
but for a while I balanced swimming and
Triathlon I remember
my uh sophomore year swimming Saturday
morning practice uh the officer rep for
our tri-team was waiting outside the
pool brought me to the airport I flew to
Tennessee unpacked my bike did the
triathlon race that Sunday flew back
home Sunday night was back in the water
Monday morning at you know 5 30 or
whatever right some coach never knew
some coach would have flipped kicked me
off the team if he knew but I was trying
to balance both uh-huh and then I did
Wildflower at the end of my uh sophomore
year which at that point was Collegiate
Nationals and I got 11th I dropped my
chain on that big hill coming out of
transition but I was a top guy in the
Naval Academy team and I thought hey
maybe there's something here maybe I can
be good at this and that's where I said
okay
I'm gonna stop assuming even though I
had some of my best races at the end of
that year
stop swimming and said okay let's go all
in on Triathlon interesting yeah prior
to that uh you you had mentioned to me
that you you had pursued like dive
school for a minute yeah like tell me
what happened okay so I've never told
the story Rich so this is all right
pretty embarrassing but yeah I went to
Berkeley
um you know got my masters in Ocean
engineering there and I service selected
when I was still at the Academy Special
Operations which is explosive ordinance
disposal and part of that is doing the
EOD
dive training so I go to my command and
I had already found like the best
situation ever where I'd had the support
from Navy Sports uh and my commanding
officer to pursue the Olympic dream so I
had convinced the Navy to be like all
right this guy's got something special
I'd won the Armed Forces uh National
Championship in Triathlon like okay
we're going to support this guy
but I still had to go to dive school
first and do that
so I come from the Olympic Training
Center finished up the season and I'm
like so you're hold on just sorry
there's a lot going on here I told you
all right the Navy deployed you to the
Olympic Training Center they did yeah
like you were you were officially like
in you know an armed service uh officer
but you were there to just train
Triathlon and be at the Olympic Training
Center that was yeah it was uh more of a
you're like being paid or like yeah
you're a normal you're I was still an
ensigner I was like maybe Lieutenant
Georgie at that point because the first
couple uh promotions are automatic but
uh the army army and Air Force have
world-class athlete yeah of course and
yeah Fort Carson outside of Colorado
Springs is where the Army's basically
maybe didn't have that so I had to kind
of
yeah so actually you know what happened
rich is um I put together this like
packet promotions packet and I sent it
to the head of Navy Sports it was I mean
professionally done uh-huh and uh the
Navy personnel offices in all places is
in Millington Tennessee but it lands on
uh his desk
and just like as he's looking at it the
top ranked EOD guy
on the west coast who is going to be my
like head honcho boss walks by his door
and he says sir take a look at this
and uh Captain Hines looked at it he's
like this is awesome like these are the
type of people we want in the Navy like
let's yeah let's promote this so bam all
of a sudden um there you go you know I'm
heading to Colorado Springs
sort of as a and you know from a
promotional perspective like you're like
a poster boy exactly for recruiting Etc
so we do PR and things like that I would
go to dive tanks and Denver and um but
let's talk about the dogs
so I go there I'm a little overconfident
I'm like I'm super fit yeah you know
finished in the Race season but I didn't
really prepare properly which
I should have known right
and I get there and all the instructors
are just waiting for me like they wanna
they wanna fail you so badly not only am
I Junior officer and these are all
senior enlisted so these guys are like
they're in it they know everything and
they're like ah look at this little run
um but I'm also like I'm almost like the
boss's pet too right like his project so
I had a Target on my back which I didn't
know at the time I was a previous I'm
just like
so I get up uh for the physical
the physical tests at the start of the
high school
and I go and I do my pull-ups and I have
a I have a six six wingspan and I'm
barely six feet tall so I'm like kind of
misproportioned not great for doing
pull-ups yeah and uh I do my pull-ups I
get off the bar I do like one or two
extra over the minimum which I think was
eight or nine and uh I feel like you
failed
like what I'm like yeah no yeah like
three of those didn't count your chin
didn't go all the way over the bar you
didn't tell me that like you know
they're like you're off the bar like and
they're just kind of messing with me
uh-huh so they're like okay well you
gotta like do a retest and
if like if you fail to retest you're out
so they're not kind of like panic I get
in panic mode I got two days or whatever
it's a weekend all the other guys are
going off and partying over the weekend
and I'm just like trying to do pull-ups
all weekend well it's like the worst
thing to do right so you show up
exhausted talk to the retest I could
barely lift my arms and I didn't do I I
didn't do it I didn't get there and I
had to go to the board and basically
they're like all right yeah we have to
boot you out but at the same time
they're all scratching their heads
because like they're like oh this this
went terribly wrong like we weren't
expecting this guy who topped his class
at the Academy yeah and you know
professional athlete like this is a
weird situation right so I get political
Firestorm yeah yeah I get booted out and
I'm like ah you do the breath hold stuff
and all the other aspects of the test
though uh this was like before all oh
yeah so that this is like a precursor
yeah right at the beginning yeah um so
it's like like you're revolving door
like you're gonna do the gate yeah like
all right so I'm like I'm like I'm
shocked they're shocked uh I'm like I
don't know what's gonna happen like
am I just gonna go to the fleet and like
have to like be a surface Warfare
officer I don't know uh-huh
luckily the uh they made an exception
like all right we're gonna like this is
don't tell anyone yeah yeah just we're
gonna put you back in next class so I
went back to my command and Coronado
um for I don't know it was eight weeks
or whatever and like they're like just
your only job is right go to the bull
bar outside the building and just make
sure you do this so I end up going back
and I had some Redemption
um you know I did I don't know I did way
more than I needed to do and then ended
up um you know I was a class leader and
ended up being the undergraduate so the
top graduate in the class ah but I still
oh man along the way that those those
eight weeks however long class was and I
had everybody after me I remember
we were um you know they
you have to pass all these tests like
breath hold and things like that and
they have one where they just beat the
crud out of you when you're on the
bottom with your tank on they pull your
tank off they tie all your tubes you rip
all your stuff off yeah and you've got
to sort it all out and the master chief
of the dive school he's like
uh my buddy was up top and they're like
all right who's up next like O'Donnell
he's like I got him I got him so he
comes because it does a number on me and
writes on a little chalkboard like I
finally get my uh my mask back on he
writes on chalkboard for the race good
luck like good luck with this one and I
did it and I got through it and he's
like okay all right this you know maybe
this guy's okay and right you get you
had to do it with a Target on your back
yeah and I actually got uh amazing
letters from my two um the two uh
instructors in my class are like
really yeah thank you like you did an
amazing job we really appreciate you
sticking that through and
so it all you know all as well it ends
well but it was it was hairy yeah and
and uh any thought of of kind of you
know joining the special forces or being
seal or anything like that I was the
only I was the only guy on the try team
my senior year which is probably five or
six of us I didn't go seals I was the
only all my all my buddies are on seal
yep yeah they're all team six guys now
or you know they're getting out and
stuff but
it's an interesting kind of time that
we're in and maybe this has a lot to do
with like social media and the internet
but
um you know the the the kind of
um
Ascension of of the special ops officer
as as you know kind of a celebrity you
know what I mean like whether it's books
that are being written or just uh people
that you know impart wisdom on podcasts
like there's a lot of energy around you
know SEAL Team Six guys Etc
um and it's cool it's cool to like learn
from these guys and and uh
you know try to you know extract from
their experience something that's that's
actionable but
um as somebody who you know has a
background in this like how do you like
what is your perspective on all of that
how do you look at all of that like
whether it's you know Goggins or Jocko
willink and these guys are you know that
are out there and you know people love
these guys and Goggins also like being
you know he you know part of his career
was you know not dissimilar and that he
was sort of uh you know kind of on tour
yep
doing a lot of talks you know on behalf
of the Navy and there's that famous you
know commercial that he shot where he's
running you know like I think they even
aired that during Iron Man you know and
yeah one point I think before I started
doing Kona they I think they had some of
the seals like they sponsored the race
and they had seals like Drop in he was
one of those guys
yeah exactly I think he was one of those
guys that did it yeah I did that that
year it's hard because you get you get
split like splits support you know
people think it's awesome but then you
know in the service and other people
like oh you're not doing your job that
you were supposed to do right
um so that's right you're you're like
you're the the shiny thing that they're
dangling in front of other people while
we're actually out here like doing the
gigs right exactly but I mean there's
value I think one of the biggest
mistakes the Navy made was David
Robinson back in the day oh yeah they
should have had him in his whites going
into every game yeah like imagine that
he's he's got his whites on like officer
and gentleman you know going into the
Arenas like there was there's value to
that and I mean
there's Duty can be served in so many
different ways and I actually really
struggled with that when I got out of
the Navy my time was up at the end of 08
I just missed the um Olympic team by a
couple spots at trials
and I felt guilty that I I didn't do
what I was supposed to do in the Navy
you know I'd signed up to be a EOD
officer and I'd gone and done this crazy
path and
they had supported me so well and it it
really it was eating at me like what
should I do and luckily my department
had Kevin childri who
had been actually winning in his early
enlisted days
um actually did Triathlon like
professionally for a little while
and he sat me down and he's like Tim
uh
you've like you don't write your own
orders
you've done what we've asked you to do
by the way you're way behind your year
group you're never going to get promoted
past like 04 Lieutenant Commander so
you've kind of shot yourself in the foot
with your Navy career
and you have potential to do something
great in Triathlon so don't let don't
let the thought of
you know
being here to serve in another way holds
you back like you've done what we've
asked you to do now go follow your dream
and uh that was a really big moment for
me yeah and is that
that informs you know like back to that
thing of like okay you know clearly like
you put a lot of thought into the kit
that you wear and all of that so so like
allegiance to that sensibility is part
of the reason why you know like you you
kind of comport yourself the way that
you do absolutely I mean I look at
Triathlon as a gift that
the men and women of armed services
really gave me you know without the
support of the Navy when I was in the
Navy or even learning about Triathlon
we're not was at the Naval Academy
my life would be completely different I
mean yeah I wouldn't have my wife or
kids right now right I mean if I wasn't
in the sport that it all stems from that
uh so I'm uh eternally grateful to uh
our armed services and and everybody
that's quite part of it it's cool
um you know when when the day of
retirement comes like what is that do
you have any sense of what that looks
like for you I mean are you gonna are
you gonna like you know dig into that
engineering background or you know are
you gonna I'm gonna give you a little
piece of advice Rich if you see a boat
yeah don't do not step on a boat that
says it's designed by me all right I
don't all right no I'm well past that I
look at my engineering I'm confident
that if you decided to explore that that
it would be it would work yeah no I'm
I'm it'd be too I'm too far removed from
that uh I think the engineering piece of
my education is great for problem
solving which has really played well
into what I yeah Iron Man racing I mean
it's all giant puzzle right there's so
many different things you're trying to
put together on the fly when you're on
the racing
I don't know I mean
I want to do I want to put the energy
into Triathlon into something else and
try to have that success
I don't really fully know what that is
yet yeah Irene and I are going to start
a
like an age group coaching business
focused on we won't be we're not going
to be high performance coaches we're not
going to look to coach
um the next rainy you know Iron Man
World Championship we've seen
we've looked for balance as much as we
can in being professional athletes and
we've seen how hard triathon can be
on families particularly Asian families
when you're working jobs you have kids
and then you're trying to train for an
Iron Man so yeah we're looking to okay
next step is let's integrate Triathlon
into
people's Lifestyles so it's a healthy
part you know you know there's that
saying like if you're not if you're
still married you're not training hard
enough yeah it's like we don't want that
Iron Man Widow yeah I know
I know so that's that's going to be kind
of a big I think part of The Next Step
because we do want to stay connected to
the sport
on top of that I'd love to get into
public speaking I think that would be
really fun I think you'd be really good
at that thanks yeah and I've been
messing around with some real estate
investment stuff that I think will
probably be a part of it too cool
um what is what is the you know on that
coaching tip like what is the advice
that you would give
the you know amateur the enthusiastic
amateur like you've been to a million
races a million Iron Mans you've seen
these people out there like what are the
common mistakes that you see people
making that are easily avoidable like if
you have a minute just be like please
stop doing this thing that I always see
people doing over training with
everybody over trains like I mean I
understand if you're you are trying to
be a professional and get there like you
got to put the work in but if
if you're if you're over trained for
what you all the other stuff you have in
your lifestyle you're gonna hit the race
course yeah unprepared in the sense of
uh you know just not being able to
access the work you've done and that and
get a coach
um or get on a program and find some
people around you that you can train
with and share the enthusiasm enjoyment
with and
talk about it with your family you know
don't make those plans by yourself make
them make them as a family it's
definitely a joint uh it is everybody's
got to invest in it right everybody has
to be bought in or it's not going to go
well right and if you're going to try to
train 20 25 hours a week and you have
kids and a job and all of that I mean
tough man where did you max out on
training hours back in the day I mean
the mo the most yeah yeah I mean maybe
like short periods of like 22 to 25 but
a lot of 20-hour weeks and then probably
the vast majority 15 hour weeks and that
was freaking hard like that's not
sustainable no you know
so
yeah if you're a pro if you're a Gustav
and Christian and you don't have
girlfriends and like you're pretty
you're just like you're in your 20s and
this is what you do great you know most
people that is not you know that's not
gonna work so so
it's taking your tip from that yeah you
know yeah and try to figure out how to
root what you're trying to accomplish
balanced against the other things that
you that are valuable in your life and I
think you can put more energy at that
level for an Asian competitor wanting to
really enjoy the sport put more energy
into the some of the other details you
know get a proper bike fit or you know
learn about nutrition things like that
like make yourself as sufficient as
possible
so your success can come from something
else other than just training 20 or 25
hours a week yeah yeah and and the the
training being for the most part you
know joyous and nourishing as opposed to
draining and you know denigrating into
the other aspects of your lives I was um
talking to a age group athlete a couple
weeks ago and she
had like full-on train for this Iron Man
was over train did horrible
I got on a separate program that was
like 10 hours a week 12 hours a week and
ended up the next year doing better
doing so much better yeah and she
enjoyed it
you know what's great on that is uh is
Gordo Byrne yeah I'm sure you know Gore
everybody in Boulder knows everything
yeah guys so wise yeah amazing
um the last thing I want to talk to you
about before I let you go is is uh kind
of the current state of the union of of
triathlon professional Triathlon
um and and
um this issue of
of athlete representation in sport which
I think you know you know you're very
immersed in in terms of triathlon but
also I think is is
um
uh you know relatable outside of just
Triathlon itself like like the the role
or the pat like the power dynamic
between the athlete and the
organizations that you know kind of
um control the trajectory of an of a
professional athlete's career yeah I've
been uh involved in some forms since
2014 of the athletes trying to
um put themselves in a better position
and it's it's not it's never been about
like trying to go against Iron Man you
know oppose them
Rooney and I have made our careers
really off of Iron Man right like
without Iron Man You're gonna be very
politic right yeah yeah a good Navy man
I'll say what you can't say which is
which it like
the WTC all right
I mean it's a massive conglomerate uh it
it it it makes a lot of money hosting a
lot of races uh it's very profitable in
what it does
um and and
it's a beautiful thing in that it allows
you know a massive number of amateurs to
compete alongside professional
Professionals in the sport which is
really cool thing you know I think it's
amazing but I think that the sport you
know like really you know caters to that
amateur experience in a beautiful way
but does not do enough to take care of
the professionals who are dedicating
their life to Elite Performance
especially in a sport where you can only
compete at the at your Peak a couple
times a year like how many Iron Mans can
you do and these purses
don't cut it and the parody between men
and women like there's so many problems
here that need to be solved yeah and I
think it all starts with the fact that
they're an event company right they
aren't like yeah they're like we're
almost inside it's not that different
than like putting on concerts you know
the fact that it's Sports almost is but
I mean they'll sell out and this is
probably their argument they'll sell out
a an Iron Man that they're there's
without a pro race right so it's all
it's almost always like do they need
pros and that's because
we haven't been packaged as a product
that we can sell you know we haven't
been packed as as entertainment and
I think
I mean it's like why was everybody so
mad at Lance with all this stuff it's
because
he was seen as inspiration not
entertainment right people didn't look
to him as an entertainment feature like
the NFL guys that are you know pounding
each other and all you know doing stuff
behind the scenes or whatever
uh and I think we're kind of we've been
stuck in that inspiration role and
that's why it is awesome that we're
interacting with the age group
um community at Iron Man's but it
doesn't necessarily help us grow the
sport professionally or even on on the
amateur level and that's where I think
we got something really interesting with
the PTO right now it's because we're
putting together a package of races
focused on professionals that we can put
out there I mean there's 22 23 million
uh views on television last year of PTO
events so this is something we haven't
done before being able to focus on the
pros to help kind of grow that and
it's been hard be
we had to bring together a partnership
right there's investors and then there's
the athletes and
we got to Rally athletes it's a hard
situation with athletes because we're
all it's a self-sport um kind of a
almost selfish sport
and we've never had anybody around long
enough to really believe in right like
there's always these monies coming in
like I try to buy or like yeah American
inner Bank where like there's a some
cash thrown at the athletes and
everybody grabs as much as they can and
they think it's just going to disappear
so they never really uh invest in it but
now we're a partnership you know we own
half of the PTO as athletes so we're
putting it's Sweat Equity for us we need
to get behind it and we need to make
sure this thing succeeds we need to get
the same athletes consistently racing
each other on these big stages with big
prize money but we need to get to the
point where you're not losing money just
to show up to a race and that's where
the sport is at right now I mean uh if
that's super expensive to travel to all
these exotic locations and to like bring
your bike and you know stay in hotels
and all of that and then the prize money
doesn't even cover the travel expenses
so like this it makes no sense and so
it's incumbent upon the athlete to go
out and get their own sponsorship
outside of prize money
which you know like a lot of these
companies within multi-sport like yeah
they'll give you a bike or they'll give
you product but like not a lot of money
is being thrown around unless you're at
the very highest level and that's
reserved for like I don't know five or
six people and everybody else good luck
and and now we have even more Talent
that's worth the money but the the pie
is not any bigger right I mean yeah and
when you talk about endemic you know
Bike Company what is so if you get if
you win Kona and you're a man what do
you get and if you're a woman what do
you get uh the president is equal it is
yeah what is it like 250 or something uh
no I think the win is like 125 125 125
000. yeah I know for the Iron Man World
Championship but if you get what is it
if you win you know like I don't know
the you know PGA
I mean there's Augusta there's like uh
600 100 ranked like tennis players or
600 Grand the Australian Open or
whatever you know like yeah it doesn't
make it doesn't make any sense we need
to be able to bring the money in to from
getting exposure on television to bring
in some of these other partners beyond
the sport Banks you know car companies
what is the advertising Revenue that NBC
Garners from their Ironman broadcast
I mean it's got to be because that's
always like an Emmy winning you know
production right but I believe they pay
for the television time so yeah they're
paying the
wtcy I believe Iron Man pays
them to um they buy the they buy their
time and then whatever sponsor whatever
commercials they are they bring back
into that to they they keep it right I
see
that's not a great model for No Ex like
if you want to generate Revenue off of
selling the sport as entertainment you
gotta bring it in a lot more well and
also now that it's being live streamed
you know how valuable is the broadcast
when it's however many months later
right and they finally air it yeah
that's you know and it's yeah I mean
it's all they're hard it used to be a
big thing like I don't is it still a big
thing
I think they still it's it's more of
kind of that documentary style though
versus like a true race event right
you're not watching it to see who wins
you're watching it for the pageantry
yeah yeah so the PTO that stands for
Professional triathlete Organization
correct so it's sort of a a quasi kind
of collective bargaining organization
but also uh an event you know production
company like you're you're creating
these races right that are that are
designed for uh like audience engagement
that are kind of you know playing around
a little bit with the traditional format
of what a triathlon race is and
um
to develop stories too right like
the NBA really grew when Magic Johnson
and Larry Bird came in and they had this
story this you know NCAA
Championship rivalry coming into the NBA
uh you know magic very colorful
character kind of the curmudgeon like
you know just hard worker guy and yeah
it was it was the Dynamics was awesome
right and that being able to tell
stories really lifted the sport um it's
not just about the competition it's
about the stories and and uh and the
rivalries and things like that and we've
got to be able to create uh an emotional
connection with the individuals so you
want to root for somebody right yeah
whether it's you know Dave Scott and
Mark Allen racing Toe to Toe like who
are we you know why are we watching this
why do we care about who these people
are and if it only comes like Kona once
a year on the television and you see Yan
or Rini whoever it is like once a year
you you need to have that storyline and
you need that consistency you need to be
seeing these athletes face each other
you know every other week or every
couple weeks and and you need to say
that see that play out with a definitive
winner at the end uh I think that'll be
be super um important too and
it's it's not it can't be a charity
either like this whole PTO Endeavor is
isn't a charity it's a partnership right
I mean
if you just hand out money to athletes I
mean the prize money that the PTO has
handed out in the last couple years is
insane I mean two million dollar uh end
of your bonus rankings wow a million
dollar prize purses at the uh US Open
and the Canadian uh Canadian open
this is it's a big deal that's huge yeah
that's huge progress we have to be a
business we have to be able to cover
that um you know the investors are
awesome but they're they're not they're
they're here to make money off of
business too right they they're not here
to just give us handouts yeah there has
been there is a history of like kind of
money coming in and and like the Bahrain
there's the whole Bahrain thing like is
that still a thing like I think it is is
it
um and then what's the uh when those
guys lose interest the money goes
someone's like oh actually I want to
follow cycling now so let's do a cycling
like the Crown Prince was super into
Triathlon and so it's just like a pet
project for him but but you know I don't
know a lot of money seemed to come into
the sport and then what's the other
Series where there's like a Russian
oligarch involved like that yeah right
right yeah yeah and Maca yeah
back is involved with that okay uh yeah
like I think they bought the Malibu
Triathlon so I was down there the other
you know like uh it's and then I think
what's successful about that is you know
oligarch aside is playing with the
format like the way that they kind of
you know mix it up and and try to make
it more interesting for you know
somebody's trying to just witness and
pay attention like the fan absolutely
and I think
like you get someone that hasn't seen
like um Olympic like World Triathlon
racing and the first thing they'll say
is from just being a casual viewer it's
like oh that mixed relay that's really
cool you know those so right there is
some tinkering to do with formats and
engagement to uh right to really make it
powerful but I think it comes down to
the other athletes really need to
understand that if you want to make this
work then you have to help create this
business which is the races right yeah
and from that we can generate Revenue
that then can support athlete growth and
you know developing pipelines for up and
coming athletes right you know sub
series and things like that where you
can really start to put a foundation
under the support to successfully grow
in the long term right so so when you
look at golf 10s
you know some of these other sports
where you know like the athletes do
quite well
um you know what's still missing in try
like where where is the you know so
you're you're here in town because you
had a PTO meeting right like a board
meeting right so what do you guys talk
about like what are you working on
establishing to bridge the gap between
kind of where Triathlon is versus these
other sports where the athletes are are
you know kind of being accorded pay and
respect in a in a manner in a manner
that seems you know more on parody with
what they deserve
um that's a great question rich and we
actually Chris commode has um been
brought on is current chairman running
the show and he's from the tennis world
he's you know running the ATP for a long
time so
he he sees the value in this and he
wouldn't he's got a reputation that he
wants to uphold too right he's not going
to hop onto a sinking ship right he's
here to make this thing work
I wish I could tell you more about what
we discussed all the privately yeah it's
not that non-disclosure but rest assured
yeah there is uh a great plan for um for
the future it's cool I mean I feel like
the next crop we were talking about this
Changing of the Guard at Kona like the
younger athlete like these are these are
internet native people who grew up with
social media and they intuitively
understand that as professionals like
their image and their kind of like their
you know I hate that word brand or
whatever like it's they have to shoulder
the responsibility of of you know
creating interest in what it is that
they're doing and that's just part of
their DNA whereas older people like your
generation certainly you know my you
know I'm way older uh you know that was
something that that people had to learn
or kind of resisted or or didn't think
that they had to do but that's just part
of the mentality it's like oh you're a
professional okay here's what you need
to do like you'll get sponsors because
you have a certain number of people on
Instagram who care about the
storytelling that you're doing and you
know how to tell a story to get people
interested so that when you are racing
you have a fan base and that you know
like sort of scaled up creates a lot
more interest in the sport which
ultimately will bring more right
eyeballs and money and all of that into
it yeah and it it starts from the top we
have to really engage those top athletes
right the young guys the Norwegians
because you see Gustav and Christian and
Sam and like you know they they those
guys know what they're doing yeah online
and we can't we can't
grow and unless we get the top to really
you know get on board and then you know
once we get it all established it
everything trickles down right yeah and
then we can start supporting development
things like that but really and I joke
we've been around a long time right we
we joke that we signed up to be
professional athletes but now we're just
social media influencers I mean the
shift has been insane right and we
struggle with it it's a Tim and Brittany
show I do YouTubers so we were kind of
one of the first in the in the uh in our
sport to get on that yeah like ah like
we don't like I don't know if this is
what we want to do yeah and so and but
then we kind of the floodgates opened
with all the other athletes um but hey
yeah I mean I mean Lionel's channel is
right probably gets more views than you
know than like an Iron Man no I know
yeah right yeah it's really smart you
know and you know ultimately like
you develop however many people are
interested in whatever it is you're
sharing those those people start to care
about you you know like that's that's
important that I feel like that is part
of the job you know it it definitely is
that and I think Rene and I we're good
about being able to kind of shift a
little bit yeah I mean we the old days
you just if you you know you put a logo
on a kit and you try to get on a
magazine cover that's not good you're
done you do one booth appearance at a
race yeah and those days are long gone
so yeah they're so far gone but um and
and probably for the better like what is
the value proposition of that you know
what I mean I don't like it doesn't
really make sense and I think there's
still a lot of companies that are stuck
in that Paradigm and they don't
understand like that really doesn't
matter but you know what matters is
who really cares about what you're doing
like whether you get fifth or first or
tenth is much less important than you
know how emotionally attached you know
people out in the world are to what it
is that you have to share with them yeah
and it's it's almost this kind of like
butting them heads between
story and performance right yeah they
don't all you have to perform you still
have to perform like it can't yeah do
you have to win I don't know yeah you
know yeah or I mean like if you do if
you have the credibility of if you have
a record of performance you have the
credibility that's you know obviously a
great spot but right yeah so so what's
the future of the Tim and Renny show on
YouTube
we we got to get Kenny back we're like
Kenny we need you does he live in
Boulder he does like uh yeah yeah okay
we made the mistake though we um
you know we want everybody to grow
around us too so like we you know
connected a lot of Partners and stuff
and then our partners start using them
so much uh-huh like like hey we still
need some Kenny time too yeah we're like
yeah where's our candy
yeah you got to get back on that yeah no
we're gonna uh we'd like to and I maybe
I think we have a lot to share with this
kind of transition period too right it's
not all about racing anymore for us you
know we're parents we're figuring out
what what's the rest of our life gonna
look like yeah that's a compelling story
to our audience yeah good man are you
gonna come out and be on an episode of
the show I would love to yeah all right
be honor I'd be honored too
yeah for sure
um that's a promise and if Rini that
seat is wide open for rinny anytime she
wants to oh yeah she'll um we'll get her
out of uh I used to see like when Siri
had her group out here that she was
training I think I think rainy was part
of that like he was living out here
right yeah so I would see them like over
in in
um Malibu Creek State Park they would do
a run Loop in there and and she would
they would be they would go ride as a
Peloton and she would like Drive behind
them or you know I used to see them out
and you know what Siri um she bought a
pool
she did yeah they had a pool they had
like a like one of those like above
ground like 25 meter oh I think I
ordered remember seeing something about
that yeah and it wasn't heated though
renews said it was so cold
yeah I don't know where it was but but
now she uh she like has a horse ranch so
she's a horse
[Music]
I mean
they're doing some real good up there
it's cool yeah
um well it's great to talk to you man
yeah thank you appreciate being here
this is awesome
um any any kind of like last words for
uh you know the unsuspecting uh uh you
know
um person out there who might be uh
harboring a little bit of uh arterial
plaque or the uh the aspiring Iron Man
athlete who's you know spending too much
time training and not enough time at
home like I don't know where do you
where do you want what do you want to
leave us with yeah I just think um
life is is precious and it goes by
quickly so
just make sure you're you're doing
everything you can to to enjoy the
moment and the people around you and
everything you can to make sure you're
around for as long as you can be as well
yeah I appreciate it I think your story
is really powerful and uh it's just you
know it's it's so extreme uh that you
know once you hear it or you know watch
the videos or whatever you can't it
doesn't leave your Consciousness and it
really like as somebody who you know
look I care a lot about my health but
it's inspired me to go and you know I
haven't been I haven't gotten a calcium
test in a couple years like I really
should go and and check that and I think
everybody should and I think you know
you're in a position to really you know
uh you know spread
um a message that's not only powerful I
mean let's face it like heart attacks
that's the number one killer like this
is the thing that like you know by and
large most people are going to die from
right it is the number one killer for
men and women in the U.S
I mean it's yeah it's real and yeah
ourselves and our bodies right like it
is as serious as a heart attack
we go
um cool we'll uh come back and talk to
me again sometimes it's super fun I'll
let you know next time I'm in uh Boulder
I want to come in I know the house from
the videos
for myself that's good or not
um but uh much luck to you and and uh if
there's anything I can do uh for you at
your service thanks Rich now cheers
peace